pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67
in the governor's emergency order number
12 pursuant to executive order 20
2004 this public body is authorized to
me electronically
please note that there is no physical
location for the members of the public
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen if necessary
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website the notice for
this meeting complies with health
house rules in rsa 91a anyone who has a
problem accesses
accessing this meeting should call
603-271-3600
or email hcs at
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
i'm going to start the meeting by
calling and roll as soon as i throw my
dogs out
um okay so representative lekkas
i'm at home my wife's around actually
she's on an education meeting in another
room
excellent uh representative grota i'm
here in my home office alone
uh representative linzara hi home in
nashville i do have some workers of
maybe not parking
representative schultz i am
transitioning to my computer in
concord at home shortly and my husband
will be
in and out of the room okay very good
um i hope you feel well representative
schultz you sound a little under the
weather
oh i'm fine thank you i think it's just
allergies ah
okay all right so um where we left off
we had um pretty much agreement on what
we wanted to see changed
in this um why don't we start off with
everybody's piece that they had changed
uh representative lekkis are you
prepared to tell us what
what you got changed i know it was all
circulated by mr smarling
right um so there are two aspects
one is every place that mentioned uh
this is for context this was
um grandfathering in summer camps that
that
uh you know have been grandfathered but
there was the condition that
uh it only worked if they operated
continuously
and uh some of them were not able to
operate uh
last summer due to covid and i was
concerned that at least some of them
might
not either not operate or not be able to
operate at full capacity this year
hopefully that won't happen but
we'll see and so any place that it had
uh
the summer of 2020 and i changed the
summers of 2020 and or
2021 and then we discussed
having at sunset at the end of this year
and my only concern is i don't know and
i put that in the email
i'm not sure how things are interpreted
uh
as far as the law goes um i i put
some language in there to cause it to
sunset the end of this year
but if the law goes away
are they still grandfathered in um you
know if let's say they weren't operating
last summer
the way the language works it's clear
that uh you know they could operate
this summer they'd still be
grandfathered in but my concern
was if the language uh you know if it
expires the end of this year they can
have a problem next year
and i think it would make sense that
they wouldn't
but i don't know how that works and i'm
wondering if there's a lawyer in ols who
could uh
uh you know could give an answer to that
so
what i'd like the amendment you know the
amendment has the uh language to cause
it to
uh to sunset and uh um
smarling if you know when you put the
thing together if you could ask them
about that
and if there's any doubt about uh
whether they would still be grandfather
going forward if it expired then just
leave that section out please
could you send me a copy of what you've
got i
sent it to the committee email address
doesn't that go to you as well or not
no it does not oh i apologize i'll do
that
okay but that's that's all there is to
it
have a question please uh miss marlin
could you
uh send me the link to this again so
that i can uh
you know raise my hand effectively
that's the conversation
sure sure
mr chairman i don't know you whether you
can see me
i was muted um just a second
i can't see you representative schultz
schmidt i mean um
representative lekis is you're concerned
that with the
sunset provision that the camps that are
able to operate this year
and last year would then not be able to
operate the following year once the
statute goes away because
they were not operating
last year is that what i'm my concern is
let's say they were not able to operate
um
last year due to covid and let's say you
know kova is not a problem this year
so you know clearly they'd be able to
operate this summer
uh but with the statue ending at the end
of this year expiring at the end of this
year would they have a problem next year
in the years going forward
um and i just don't know you know what
happens
you know how that's interpreted you know
by courts
and miss marlin i sent you i just sent
you a copy okay if we can get an opinion
i think it
i think it it would because to to say
otherwise
would be um just because the law expired
it was the law at the time
so but yeah but but it's you know it's
an issue of
looking at what their situation is going
forward after the laws expired i
i mean i think it kind of makes logical
sense that they'd be okay
uh but sometimes i know the way uh
things are interpreted does not
necessarily uh
go along with common sense logic so that
was my concern
that's crazy sorry i believe
representative lucas said if
you sunset and um
a statute then the previous statute that
applied
takes over right but they're
okay yeah he's concerned that
retroactively
they would look back and see that they
didn't operate since the statute that
allowed them to
continue grandfather because they
couldn't operate would then
affect them but i think that just a
quick opinion from all that won't kill
us
to get the confusion out of it
representative schmidt why would they
have not what would be a reason for them
not opening if they could
oh well only if they couldn't
my concern is this um is let's say they
could not open last year
um because of coded and
the uh you know this the amendment here
would uh
let them open the issue is the previous
law was that they could
continue their non-conforming use as
long as they operated every year
um oh i think i see right
and so if the statute expires then there
was a year when they had a
they were not operating and so maybe the
interpretation could be
next year in all future years they
couldn't operate i mean that'd be
kind of illogical but technically that
might be the way it would work
you could write in the amendment that
this um
you can write something in the amendment
that says that
failure to open due to covid is not a
reason
to um you can refer to that statute
and say that failure to not open
would not but would not account for
um you know not being open a year
based on unconventional use
yeah i mean if we just get rid of the
fires
if it expires that doesn't mean anything
either except for it would give
legislative intent
right so i mean the easiest thing might
be not to have it expired the only
reason i want to have it expired
is you know years from now we still have
this thing in the rsas that um
you know it was an artifact of covid but
it might actually be necessary to leave
it in that was my concern
well we'll see from ols okay
representative schmidt
well you've been kind of massaging the
issue i wanted to address mr chairman
but
uh clearly the pandemic is an
extraordinary circumstance
uh that you want to factor in and
and that's what you're trying to do
representative lekis
but but uh i think the language has to
reflect that that that
it's only the extraordinary circumstance
that um takes away the previous
stipulation that they had to be
effectively in continuous operation
and and to the degree that they
would not open for other reasons because
let's say somebody died ownership
transferred
they you know they had financial
difficulties whatever
that would not fall under the
rubric of the pandemic at all that you
have to
now you're trying to figure out how you
want to handle it and so i just think
that the language has to reflect uh the
extraordinary circumstance aspect and
nothing else because otherwise you're
going to say or if this
this or this now you're setting up all
kinds of additional
terms and conditions so the language
clearly deals only with code
right right very clear but but it
running it past an attorney is the
appropriate thing to do that's why they
that's why they study law because they
have
they need to be able to put things in
language that that meets the legal
requirements and you could you can see
we are struggling with that aspect
right i agree that's what i i asked for
uh miss marley when she put
exactly i see i see where you're going
and
putting it running it past the attorney
is the right thing to do okay
okay let's move along i don't want to
get tied up on this piece of it um
please what do you have to tell us about
the proportion you had done
are you speaking i'm sorry did you hear
did you say representative grota
i did yes okay yes so i had outdoor
dining and i got input
input from both um
uh darren from everyone actually darren
windham
um uh margaret burns and uh
rob tardif and the
document that i put together was
circulated to the to the group
um i think we have something that's
easier to say
um first of all
the amendment the part of the amendment
in red
it says so let me read it restaurants
and other food service establishments
licensed under rsa 143-a code 4
shall be permitted to expand outside
whenever an outdoor
dining area can be set up safely such as
parking space
close to the entrances sidewalks
existing patios
lawn areas or other appropriate areas
provided that
and then there was um this issue about
um municipal
wastewater systems whether it be a
septic tank or
a sewer so the original language that
was sent to me by des said that if the
restaurants or food establishment is
served by a waste disposal system as
defined by rsa no additional seating
shall be allowed without first obtaining
approval
from from des
i took i'd like to take that out and say
for establishments that
are on municipal sewer they can expand
seating as the municipality
allows because the sewers are municipal
yeah so that's okay with everyone the
this sentence would be or other
appropriate areas
provided that for establishments that
are on municipal sewer
they can expand seating as the
municipality allows
and then new hampshire
municipal association out of the
sentence outdoor dining expansions
are subject to all other applicable
local
regulations and ordinances very good
so that clarifies the wishiwashi
um well let's not call it that let the
unclear reference to local
rule so and then the rest of it stays
the same
so what i can do is if everyone agrees i
can send
to you all that new
condensed version yeah send it to um ms
smarling too please because she's
going to wrap all this together into one
um one
amendment okay um did anyone else
besides me have
anything that they were getting
i guess not so let me
find the changes i did
senator roy representative allegro seems
to have his hand up oh thank you i
appreciate that hold on a second go
ahead representative
thank you i'm not sure if this is the
right time in the scheme of things but
it was brought to my attention today and
this is hard for me to keep track of so
uh i hope i'm not referring to something
that has already been fixed
uh but on page three uh lines
16 to 20 is a section that begins with
current and former military service
members
military state a specialty code
it has one for the army it has one for
the air force but it was brought to my
attention that there's nothing for navy
quite foreign page 3
16 to 20.
i just want to say to representative
allegro it's nice to
know what you look like you on my
computer previously showed up as a very
very tiny
uh undiscernable dot and
lovely to see what you look like
i'm sorry could you kindly um refer
which you're talking about uh
sp155
page three lines 16 to 20 and starting
on line 16
section 4 says current and former
military service members
who have been assigned a military
occupational specialty code
of 68w in parentheses army
or 4no 4n0x1
parentheses air force with or without
additional
skill and so on and a constituent
brought to my attention that it
didn't mention navy corn
so this is in reference to the temporary
health partners
yeah i assume he's talking about it it
lets former military medics
be able to uh to use this
if they've been doing it within the last
three years and it's only just the air
force in the army
um so what we need is uh the military
occupational specialty number
mos or whatever it's called in the navy
for an av
corpsman i wonder if we can just say
but military without getting into the
specific
i mean because we're going to forget the
coast guard and we're going to forget
the marines and we're going to forget
the space force
representative roy yes sorry to
interrupt
but this section should actually be
deleted here
because we dealt with this in a house
bill
and we resolve the issue of the
of all the forces and the proper codes
and this so this section is duplicative
i forget what number it is i think it's
house bill 145 but i'll i'll get it to
you
that particular section is unnecessary
and should be deleted
i'll send you on
well that saves us a lot of work thank
you for interrupting glad to help
um okay so can i just clarify what needs
what will be deleted it looks like
section
four um just paragraph four
on this in this section page three lines
sixteen
through nineteen
okay i just wanna make sure i understand
the the
request if you're just taking out
paragraph four
yeah let's wait until um representative
maguire sends
if representative mcguire if you can
send it to ms smarling too
just to make sure the language is um
you know what i mean that it matches up
is that good you got that covered mr
smelly well
you know i i'll wait to hear from
representative mcguire i'm
i'm not you know confident that
that's that does it i mean if it does
that's great
but i yeah well we'll just do a side by
side and make sure that it's
the issues covered and taken care of and
if it is then we'll just delete
that paragraph i will just add that was
an incorrect bill number i just looked
up house bill 145
and it's a different title and it was
killed so
okay well that's why we're going to hold
off and wait and zero
and the other question is is has that
house bill that she's referring to
past the senate uh-huh
yeah well we'll we'll we'll put a pin in
that and um
if if it has been does everyone agree
that that we can delete that section if
it's been
taken care of in another bill that looks
like it's going to pass or has passed
absolutely yes
yeah all right right so um
my section that i had to take care of
was the definition
what did a temporary health partner
actually mean
and defined it if i could find
[Music]
the language mr smarling sent me in this
plethora of emails i have
so the definition of a temporary health
partner is going to mean is
the definition will be means a health
partner who has been hired under the
process
authorized according to federal and
state waivers
so the concern we had was what did that
mean temporary health partner how long
would it last
is it are we creating a whole new
section of
uh employee or lna a whole new
classification
so i spoke to the
people at the nursing and they don't
want this to be
necessarily a new a new um
alternative way to get your license
permanently this is just
for for for the people who worked under
the cove state of emergency
so the definition therefore applies only
to people who were hired
under the state of emergency federal or
because of the
nursing homes are regulated by the by
the federal government
much more than the state and they're
very particular about
waivers and such so this
in this bill for the purposes of this
bill temporary health partner would mean
people that were hired
under this waiver granted by the federal
government and the state because of
covert
does everyone follow that i understand
i would just say i would be supportive
of looking at this
um not in a way obviously that would
hurt anything with federal regulations
um but i would still be open to this
being something we look at permanently
i'm glad you said that because after
conversation with the um
folks over there uh they are very
interested in
us doing something like that in the fall
so perhaps we could co-sponsor something
i would love to work with you on that
yeah i i agree as well
um yeah and i told her when we talked
about it and
and um the idea of an alternative
pathway
to for people who can't afford the
upfront money because the problem is to
go to the class
you have to come up with the upfront
money you'll get reimbursed but if you
don't have the upfront money
um you just can't do it so
be a problem yeah yeah so we can work we
can work on it massage it and look at it
um
in the fall so does everyone okay with
that definition
can you please just repeat it one more
time
i was trying to listen to everything i
sort of lost to the original if you
don't mind please no that's fine
um okay so the we were concerned that
there was no definition of what
temporary health partner meant
so the what it's going to mean is that
a temporary health partner means a
health partner who has been hired
under the process authorizing authorized
according to federal and state waivers
okay so very simple only people that
were hired under this
state of emergency and were granted
waivers by the state and federal
government would be the people eligible
to do this
okay thank you that's what i thought the
final outcome was
yeah does that section then be included
in the repeals in the back part of the
bill
um
seems logical to do that if what what
are you asking the representative
if it's going to be included in the
repeals in the back part of the
bill all the definition you mean
well the yeah the category i guess you
would say
the section um mr marlin
are you with us i am i am
um i think the the idea was that we
we we wouldn't know when the pandemic
might end and
and when this this position would not
be covered by the federal waiver it's
it's so tied in with
federal waiver and so
but when the federal waiver is pulled
away
then the authorization for it disappears
so that's the difficulty with
identifying a date
unless you try to craft a contingency
but it seemed
um you know the other issue that we
talked about yesterday was putting this
into session law rather than
statue um so it
had less of a feeling of permanence
yes that's right um revised language so
that amend session law
rather than obviously 360 230 excuse me
326b
so does that does that answer your
concern
representative yes i think that would be
appropriate okay i do see representative
mcguire's hand up also
i i think representative mcguire did you
want to speak again
i didn't know that it ever got lowered
from the first time
actually yes thank you mr chair it's
house bill
567 it would replace
lines 20 through 24 on page 3
which is roman 4 and 5 and
i was trying to research the question
of coast guard and other military codes
because this came up when we were
dealing with the house bill
and somehow
it resolved in favor of the language in
uh house bill 567
however uh if that is still in the
senate
it has not yet passed um
so you could either add
a modify these to the language of house
bill 567
or just delete them or put in a clause
that this section doesn't apply if 567
uh passes and i like that
anyway i will try and find the link why
we didn't
worry about the other services they may
have the same codes as
army or air force uh i don't know
exactly
i don't remember exactly what we
resolved but i remember that we did in
fact resolve it
okay um i like the idea of uh
putting a clause in that says this
section shall not apply if
um five was it five sixty four you said
passes
five six five six seven
by six i agree that that's the simplest
way
to resolve that does everyone on the
committee subcommittee agree
to do with that we'll just have some
lines okay mr marlin do you have that
sorry yes i do um we'll we'll
need to just review all this once we
get a little firmer in the amendment but
absolutely i've made a note of it
thanks okay so i believe that that
covers
um everything that we were going to
discuss um
with this bill does anyone have any
further comments or questions
all right let me just okay
let's see none i will go ahead and call
the roll
um let me see are we calling this as
amended
or
is that how we would do this one
which which where are we going we're
going to
vote i'm going to make a motion but i
need to know if i should call it
as amended or because
yeah it would be amendments discussed in
these sections
per the subject yeah okay
all right i'm going to make a motion of
ought to pass
wait peter wants to say something i
think we have to do this in committee
not
not in subcommittee
well we have to we have to vote on the
subcommittee yeah
thank you very much mr chairman so i
heard you say
the bill uh and the bill uh
also well it doesn't yet contain the
non-germain amendment because that
hasn't yet been adopted by
the committee uh but are you intending
to uh to incorporate
the non-german amendment into your
motion uh
in in in the just in the vote or is that
something that's
extraneous at this point that's
extraneous at this point the non-german
amendment is actually scheduled for a
public hearing next week
because it was so non-germane that it
was inappropriate to not
um i thank you very much for that
clarification i think that's important
and
i'm i had not heard that there was going
to be a public hearing
but i fully agree with that thank you
yeah
they just clarified that which jerk
there have been more than one
non-german amendments on some bills is
this the one that's about
uh it's about vaccines so the vaccine
part is going to be a separate amendment
now and is it with the
provisions about outdoor dining
um no the
the vaccine portion is it's going to be
its own
separate hearings yeah a separate year
right but it has to be amended
it has to be attached to something it's
not a the non-jermaine amendment is not
a separate bill it has to be attached to
something
so if it's not attached to this bill
then well it's going to be attack
we're going to attach it to this bill
but it's as it's a non-german amendment
we have to have the public hearing
no no that that's i'm not disagreeing
with with that aspect at all
but representative schultz i think was
unclear as to whether it's going to be
attached and it would have to be
attached to this
but it will come after the separate
public hearing
yeah that's correct so what we're doing
in the subcommittee right now is we're
just going to
vote that the changes we made are
approved by the subcommittee
and refer it to the um to the full
committee right at which point we'll
have
we're gonna have the public hearing on
the laundromat amendment first before we
take up the actual whole
right that's good process yes
we could just for clarification when we
talk about the motion
um to accept these we're talking about
the summer camps
the outdoor dining and the
health partners so let's make sure that
in the motion we mentioned these three
things so that there's no confusion as
to what we're voting on
i said hunky dory sounds good wait now
i'm confused again because the amount of
law was just wasn't just outdoor dining
it also included the
vaccine portions no we didn't discuss
that today chris
i mean we didn't discuss that today i'm
saying the amendment i saw about
outdoor dining page two continuing that
amendment
was vaccines so that's why i'm confused
yes representative schultz the
that was an amen the non-jermaine
amendment included something on outdoor
dining
but the amendment that you
that your committee has worked
subcommittee has worked on
about outdoor dining eliminates the need
for the
that portion of the non-german amendment
okay that makes that a lot easier i've
been
and since we're mentioning it briefly i
would say there's
possibly portions of the vaccine
component that
maybe i could support um the longer
newer version obviously is a little more
controversial but anyway
planted that seed moving forward yeah
and we'll all we'll all have a chance to
kick that around
at the public hearing next week and see
what we can come out with
so okay so um does everyone on the
subcommittee it doesn't have to be i
guess an official uh
official vote because but does everyone
um
approve of the changes that
representative groter just discussed
with specificity to the definition of
the healthcare partner
the summer camps and the outdoor dining
yes yes
representative excuse me representative
blenzara
yes very good okay
well then um without further ado i will
end this sub community hearing i
appreciate you guys all coming and
enjoy your beautiful weekend and um
we'll be back next week all right thanks
bye-bye bye everybody